hello guys reg here John here Merry
Christmas it's Christmas Eve right now
I left a family Christmas party early
just to watch the alien covenant red
band trailer before we do that I don't
even shower to my sister who drew
colored this whole photo for me is full
picture Ryan Gosling and drive one of my
favorite movies of all time
got a replace it with this one brother
hand-drawn by Jessica Alba yeah yeah
it's funny yeah I'm sorry the Jessica
Alba jokes been funny for the last like
15 years of my life and covenant after
the loved Prometheus everyone thought
that that entire movie was beginning to
end was fresh with you especially then
yeah he doesn't got better here we go
cats ooh
Oh
[Music]
Oh Christmas
[Music]
[Music]
hmm it's not gonna be so paradise II
gonna go wrong
[Music]
Oh No here are you sure about this
captain how do you mean I didn't know
yours in this yeah what the [ __ ] up
there
[Music]
dad that's bad for everybody
Oh Billy Crudup
[Music]
whoa uh-oh
gross see it's in premium large-format
what does it mean not not during sexual
stuff not during yeah not during like a
shower is that happening in Alien movie
yet where like people are doing it and
then the Ailee is you know morph comes
er I've only seen the third and fourth
one in like flashes I've like caught
chunks of them on TV and stuff no that's
disturbing I don't know if it's ever
happen in a shower that's like a slasher
movie movie
yeah exactly I was thinking Michael
Fassbender said that there's gonna be a
new kind of alien to like called a neo
morph or morph EXL tentatively
anticipate this is the thing about this
this movie trailer right here is there
some stuff I really like and there's
stuff that I'm still like I don't know
what do you I don't know about I just
because you know I've been stoned before
with this and just the way again like
the way from Prometheus on until now
they've been like no no no it's not
gonna be alien and then it became this
whole thing over time so like now I'm
just I don't know what to think about
this movie just just isolate this
trailer alone [ __ ] awesome like this
yeah makes me believe this is gonna be
rad but Prometheus did that too so a
little bit like okay cautiously
optimistic it's a teaser trailer
essentially I like you Tom it's
advertises it a fish as an official
trailer I'm really hoping this time
around we will get some answers we
talked about so they're supposed to be
to Michael FAAST members right there's
like fuzz oh yes the one Michael
Fassbender who was like decapitate it
and there's another Michael FAAST better
there's another robot that stuff I'll
see like this seems like a cool blend of
Prometheus and alien to me cuz you know
you're still outside these like weird
landscapes and stuff you see like
they're still probing the universe for
the answer yeah um and I hope you get
some answers this time it's like the
alien stuff about this trailer like is
super duper cool and like the more
Prometheus II moments I'm a little
curious about well yeah I mean I don't
want them to just can everything
from Prometheus and just yeah lead into
like alien again cuz I'm like wait a
minute you guys said up so many question
yes that a lot of us were really upset
that we didn't get a [ __ ] answer I was
hoping that cheddar will lead to like
like at least hint at that they are
actually going to answer some of those
questions yeah this looked a lot just
like you know an alien format of a movie
yeah yeah that's me Prometheus I go
explore another planet alien they they
go explore this planet they find all the
Z no more the xenomorph eggs and [ __ ]
here it seems like there's a very
similar setup happening I'm really
hoping that these are still strongly
connected you know them yeah this is a
direct follow-up to Prometheus more than
it is leading into the first alien movie
the thing about this is you know like
with with as much as it seems like their
idea has changed all I want to know or
all I'm hoping for is that they found
some kind of story that does you know do
this all justice and does make this you
know a necessary thing sure it seems
like his plan has drastically shifted
and so it's it's wicked cool to see a
suspenseful looking you know
uncomfortable even gory alien movie
again I hope that this feels like an
organic movie I really like the
intensity of the opening sequence when
the barrels running in the hallway and
the way the magic said it looked like it
was a GoPro shot at first but it's not
that's when it's like okay this is cool
really Scott like cinematography skills
coming in hand here yeah it almost looks
like found footage or something yeah it
is just like a weird low angle and it's
like really really shaky yeah it does
give it like this really immediate
intensity this scene alone like got me
really excited yeah it was violent with
this stuff and he's like the things
breaking out of his back and it is more
than just alien because you know alien
we all know it's the chest bursting
think yeah so I do feel like from that
opening scene alone that it will be a
cool hybrid of what we got from
Prometheus and hey lien where you will
have this you know more if you will have
a new neo more forever it's called and
then you'll still have that stuff in
prometheus
where like bodily dysfunction [ __ ]
starts occurring that opening scene was
like alone very intense and it's cool
that a lot of the actors that are really
being showcased in this trailer I'm not
that from
with with these guys it's cool to see if
they're really promoting the new faces
as well yeah well it seems like they
have I like the way they cast movies
like these were they have a lot of new
faces but they also have a few faces
that you recognize from different
corners of cinema because you even got
like Danny McBride in there yeah cuz you
know usually more of a comedic actor but
you he could probably fit I want a
comedic actor never he's he's very
serious actor he won all those Golden
Globes for Best Actor drunk HBO show
yeah harvesting all wrong comedies on
HBO eastbound around about you know yeah
well be a growing exert healthy that
scene where they're talking about a plan
she's like you know what is what does
she say she's [ __ ] we don't even know
the [ __ ] out there yeah like I always
remembered those scenes in Alien movies
where people are like in a mess hall
like carrying about something cuz that's
part of the charm is these they do let
their characters just kind of have to be
on this ship together like you always
get a sense for how long this is taking
you know and those scenes I always
appreciate and the crew tends to have a
more positive attitude in the very
beginning of this always until [ __ ]
really hits submitted yeah I mean the
film looks creepy and eerie you know
when it was announced and he's like
we're doing an alien like prequel it
looks more like what we probably wanted
when we first heard of dia even the
concept of Prometheus kind of sucks the
show that Billy Crudup pretty much gets
killed you know yeah unless that's like
really deceptive metadata yeah but I
don't yeah it is he looks like an overly
yeah yeah like if you look at the
trailer and this hundra there's just
scenes like the shower scene at the end
at the beginning scene that's very
intense very creepy more suspenseful
than anything you know the Prometheus
movie and it like really gritty yeah
yeah it's grainy there's a grainy look
about it I like that because like when
the trailers being a cool trailer yeah
it's like okay I don't know if that's
gonna be like that in the movie but when
there's just like scenes moments of the
link play out yeah it's effective so
that gives me more faith because this
when it's just moments that are playing
out it's I find it very effective yeah
exactly I just hope it's I just hope
they got a worthwhile story for this I
want a lien to not lose its solar it
kind of has that but even the balance
people debate you know like it and they
still like kind of get out there with
the story instead of going back in on
themselves you know like going back to
the stuff that we know and we know that
we love you know
it's true and with as much as they've
really turned this from not alien into
pretty much alien you know I makes me
wonder you always got to be wary of the
franchise now
well Studios know what to do better than
any filmmaker out there so if Ridley
Scott says I don't want to make this all
about alien I want to see I've been a
fact I wanted to steer more away from
alien um if the studio says no I'd go
with the studio they know what their day
no you have our cert or nat the real
rejects you guys are always right anyway
guys what do you think the alien
covenant trailer did you like it did you
love it are you worried huh if you're
new the channel subscribe today become a
reject no get accepted whatever the
catchphrases John Reese's Jerry on
Twitter my Instagram I give it a very
good to almost masterpiece right the
rating system no that's all right
there's no trailer readings as though we
should have one just like your movie
we're gonna go see it BAM there's our
rating said okay cool
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas and a
Happy New Year but we'll see you before
then unless you're watching this you're
just getting on my nerves sorry sorry
it's the Christmas I hate Christmas it's
the Christmas Christmas sorry I just
have way too much Christmas John and I
will be announcing a new schedule that
we will have an actual like schedule for
the real rejects we'll be putting that
up next week so keep a lookout for that
for when you'll know when to tune in for
us
you
[Music]